e
let me turn on the all right
uh
chair
start oh let me make it
official okay travel opening the
uh committee conference on House Bill
194 chair recognizes representative
gerana from uh to speak to address the
committee on its on on the
bill thank you Mr
chairman honorable
colleagues so uh some just some backr by
the way for the record Nick Chana uh
state representative from Kean uh
chesher District 1 uh I am also a a
professor of history at Keane State
College for almost 20 years this is one
of the first bills that I filed my the
the thought process behind it was I want
history to be something that people
engage with uh in particular thinking
about public markers and public
monuments that you know we pass by them
every day uh relatively few of us too
few of us actually stop and read the
markers and think about their meaning
and uh I think that those markers and
monuments should be opportunities for
people to to learn uh and to engage in
discussion about our our shared history
so uh I also have a lot of friends who
are social studies teachers uh in middle
schools and this would be a really great
opportunity especially around National
History Day uh for there to be an
inventory in one place on a State
website of all of our publicly
maintained monuments and we had that
wording specifically in the bill
publicly maintained uh because that kind
of Narrows the universe of objects we're
talking about here there was a question
about what what is a marker what is a
monument well every municipality has a
list of monuments and markers it
maintains right so these are lists that
already exist it's a finite Universe of
of objects and if they're all in one
place and what I would love to see is
school groups who uh get projects you
know go out and find markers in your
town and do a report on that event on
that person I would also really love it
if some you know Middle School class
were to go to City Hall and enter a
petition to have a new marker for
somebody uh say look this person is
really important in the history of our
community and they haven't been
recognized I think that would be a
fabulous way to get our young people
engaged in studying the history of our
um the of our state and the many
cultures of our state so that was the
idea uh from the beginning it was it's
an educational tool it's a very Bare
Bones approach it is literally a uh
going to be a list I worked with uh with
the division to make sure that it would
not cost anything so that it is
something that can be done with the
resources that currently exist and it's
literally just a list now if at some
point there is grant money that becomes
available to kind of build that out into
a more searchable kind of tool that
would be great uh but the intention is
for this not to add any expenses to uh
to
taxpayers so that's the history of the
underlying Bill uh was I made a very
rookie mistake this is my first term
when I first entered it uh I uh had it
the the relative Department was the uh
State archives because I'm a historian
and I think about
archives uh and that was not the
appropriate dep department so and then
with some help of colleagues uh we had
the bill amended to make sure it went to
the appropriate division as I said where
there are no additional resources
required my concern about the many have
many concerns about the amendment
um most
importantly I understand uh first of all
we have public processes uh that that
currently exist and I understand those
processes are far from perfect uh I
myself I'm on environment and
Agriculture and uh I come up against
processes that do not give the public
the input that they should have that's a
struggle I think that we all have on our
various committees when we're trying to
make executive departments more
responsive to the needs of our
constituents but processes like this are
never ever made better by making them
partisan or ideological and that is
exactly what happens when you require an
act of the legislature we probably
wouldn't be able to agree on a lunch
order in one let alone two bodies and
yet this amendment would require both
bodies to con to agree on the on wording
on specific language if you were to
amend a marker uh that process bringing
politicians and political processes into
language around a historical marker is
frankly for me as a historian
mindboggling inconceivable that one
would ever do that but also if if we're
talking about which we should be what
best serves our constituents that's not
it
making this something that we argue
about a word is this word derogatory how
old is this word let's talk about the
anemology let's talk about the history
in order to amend a
marker is unfathomable as far as I'm
concerned I I I do understand on some
level the part of the amendment that has
to do with the removal of
markers I personally am not in favor of
removing monuments and markers I'm in
favor of providing
context uh I would argue that you know
the idea that you can never take statues
down for example
is
uh simply not true we don't have statues
to King George III in American cities
anymore we took him down right that
happens when history changes when
culture changes it does happen it has
always happened in the history of this
country going back to at least the 18th
century right so but that's not what the
underlying bill is about I think more
context more discussion is always better
so I I think there's some room for a
conversation around removal of markers
but the notion that you would require
both houses of the state legislature to
come to an agreement on a language
change as I said is just unfathomable as
far as I'm concerned let's take the
processes that we have that are intended
to be responsive to the concerns of the
Republic to the public pardon me and
let's make those genuinely responsive
but as I said uh this amendment as far
as I'm concerned actually takes us
further from that
goal thank
you any comments or questions by members
committee if I may well I thank you for
I appreciate you sharing your thoughts
on this I I guess my thought is when I
introduced this amendment is that
we uh you know we're putting these
markers up and we're allowing them to be
put up by you know by the historical
preservation Society um uh the office
excuse me but I there's really not a lot
of public input and I think that once we
have these things in place it's you know
when we're looking to make an amendment
or to to change something that it's been
established as at least a piece of
history on that marker by this by the uh
preservation office now when you want to
change that or you want to remove it to
me there needs to be some public the
input of we are the represented body of
the people we're elected to do that and
it's it's our job to sort of do all
kinds of things like this we we look at
many issues that sometimes you go I
don't know sure that should be in front
of the legislature but it is you know uh
we have very good deep and thoughtful
conversations and sometimes they are
contentious but it's okay but history is
probably one of the most important
things we have and making sure that the
preservation of it I think definitely
needs to have an opportunity to go
before the duly elected representatives
of the people when we're looking to make
a change and how that is portrayed to
our public so that is why I put this up
here because I felt it was a I agree
with you it's a little bit of a heavy
process it can seem like a sledgehammer
approach but I I think it puts the topic
out in front of the people and through
their elected body and I think it's a
good process to go through before we
start trying to change these markers or
remov we've seen um some situations that
are occurring around starting to occur
in our state as well we've certainly
seen them around the country where
there's movements to try and change you
know the way we portray history and and
and if there's uh you know something
that needs to be changed I think a a
good vibrant conversation amongst the
General Court members is not a bad place
to air that
out I appreciate that context um I'm
going to try to you my two hats here
I've got my legislator hat and my
historian hat uh and I don't want
to you know go into the direction of as
I would in a in a class talking about
you know this notion of we shouldn't be
rewriting history we're always rewriting
history that's actually what historians
do it's what they have always done and
as I said if we look at the the early
the period of The Early Republic and the
ways in which the founding fathers
effectively rewrote the history of the
colonies in order to help establish a
new national identity and break away
from Great Britain and British
Traditions right so the acts of
rewriting history are actually literally
foundational as you said we don't have
statues to King George III anymore uh in
terms of being representative um perhaps
I'm just more jaded I have seen on bills
coming before the house for example when
we had hearings that had so many people
that we did it in Representatives Hall
almost every single person would be on
one side of a bill and when you look at
the online testimony almost every single
person is on one side of that bill and
it didn't pass that doesn't give me any
confidence that when we're talking
about some of these really contentious
issues that we are are being genuinely
representative I think we can do that
better by making administrative
processes more responsive because when
you talk about representative the other
issue for me is we should make it as
depoliticized as possible it's not
possible to remove it entirely but we
should minimize the extent to which
things are politicized and and this is a
good example and having it voted on by
both Chambers to me actually as you said
goes in the opposite
direction thank you can I follow oh
yeah representative I appreciate that
and I certainly seen that same situation
but you have to remember just because
someone yells loudly does doesn't mean
they represent the body and you may have
a hundred people that show up and say we
don't like this but there may be a
thousand more that didn't bother to show
up so sometimes what you're getting on
that isn't you know on a particular
topic isn't necessarily representative
of the community as a whole but it's
those Advocates who are willing to take
the time and come there so I mean we we
all get many emails and Communications
on a lot of different levels and phone
calls from from uh different people and
I've had some from my own Community who
said I email you all the time and you
don't vote the way I ask you to and I
said well you're just the one person
there there's a whole bunch more that
emailed me the other way so I'll just
remind you that just because you you may
see that on a signup sheet that isn't
necessarily representative of your whole
community and I think we are the
representative uh the elected
representative body of our communities
and we are held to that task every two
years when we have an election and if
we're not doing a good job we we don't
come back that would be my response
thank
you thank you Mr
chairman um good morning representative
I I appreciate your comments but um I
would argue that history of this country
has always been political always you
can't hide from that fact in fact you
brought up the point about the history
of The Early Republic how the founding
fathers rewrote the history it wasn't
done because they had nothing else to do
on a Sunday afternoon they had a
political point that they wanted to make
they had to position themselves on the
world stage
but so I I it doesn't bother me about
the political aspect of History um but
also I'd like to make the point that
history belongs to everyone it just
doesn't belong to the historians and
just so everyone know I am a historian
myself um it belongs to the people and
the people should have a say in what
that history is and how they view it and
that's where they come they come here
and they talk about their history their
experience and it's up to us as elected
officials to sort through and to look at
what people are saying and you do have a
group of people over here who are just
not going to agree and you've got a
group of people over here who who agree
it's our job is to walk that fine line
in between and try to find compromise
sometimes it's messy it's ugly but it
has always been that way always and we
sorted out that's our job so I don't
have a problem with having this done
through the general court this is where
you want people to come and to have
those discussions rather than see people
create a mob out on the street and tear
down monuments which we have seen happen
in this country time and time again
thank you Smith I may I
respond I want this going back and forth
yeah okay well then I probably don't
need to sit here for I'm just going to
be spoken at all right okay you can
respond no well I mean I mean if I just
mean
that that's okay just consider I mean
it's just that there is you know that we
are we do have a job to do here we've
got okay well my apologies Mr what I
mean by that I'll rephrase it is if if
we've entered into that phase of the
discussion then then I'll I'll sit back
down where where input is is not I would
I would just I think we're we can
we can just make statements and then
yeah I think we I would like to get this
have a limited amount of time so I'd
like
to represent okay I I'll sit back down
there okay uh thank you m Mr chair um my
I have a couple of points the first
point I want to make is is I as far as I
am concerned and I have heard nothing
from my colleagues um to indicate that
anyone disagrees um um until we get to
um the amendment I think there's
Universal agreement that the bill that
representative ger developed and brought
uh to the house and to the Senate is
absolutely sound and does something
that's important I I haven't heard
anyone say anything else so that means
we're focusing exclusively looking at
the side by side on the historical
markers point of view
um I am
um I'm trying to get to yes since I've
had two other Committees of conference
that I'm getting tired um and
um I want to put something before the
group to see what you think about it um
having experienced um in great detail
significantly more detail than I wanted
to experience
how the system didn't work in Durham and
how it was misused and how the
department evidenced no interest at all
in anyone's idea of History um it was
only people's feelings that were to be
considered and I did not think that was
acceptable if you don't study history
you're condemned to relive it and I
truthfully don't want relive it so um
but I understand the problems that are
raised about
expecting uh how do we involve the
legislature and so what I'm looking at
is what if uh in what is on in the side
by side uh going near the end um of the
written in regular type um need to
obtain information on the the event to
be commemorated and on the appropriate
location for the mark including
Consulting
historians and holding
local public
hearings period and getting the public
involved at the local level where there
is most familiarity with the particular
issue getting historians involved and
not people who are only worried about
touchy feely issues and then stopping at
that point and not involving the
legislature which among other things um
could um delay uh a timely uh action so
I don't know if that might be a way to
get people to agree but to me I'd like
to take a look at can we do this in a
meaningful
way and not have the legislature
involved but having the local community
involved and having historians involved
thank
you thank you
um so U Back to the bill again um
I uh I don't know if anybody else here
served on has served on historical
Resources Council but I spent a number
of years on it and that's the body that
actually does the State Highway marker
program and approves the language and so
on and so forth and uh it's a good
process and it does involve a lot of
local input because it's usually the
local folks who come forward saying they
want to have one and there they've done
a lot of historical research and and so
on so I think the council's good um but
I agree with Senator Pearl in that you
know we are the policymaking body and
it's often um good to know that there is
um
local public hearings and all that but
you know we we are the we're responsible
for directing agencies what what to do
um and uh I in my years working with
with the his Resources Council and with
that department I have found usually
there's a very good Synergy about
understanding that we set policy and
then they then helped find resources to
do it um I do have some concerns about
the full Bill process it's expensive to
file a bill got to go through hearings
in both bodies and if it's just that you
know one marker got hit by a snowplow
which happened in Baron and they then
they had to figure out where we're going
to put it now is do we want to Bill on
that um so that's why I had thought
maybe we would uh say C the approval of
the of the joint fiscal committee um
that's and these these agencies go to
Joint fiscal all the time and all kinds
of issues not just physcal ones so that
would be a way of saying that's head the
touch of the legislature and policy um
without having to go through a full Bill
process so I think that'd be another
approach I ask uh Senator Waters a
question would that could I ask you a
question go right ahead thank you you
won't get a good answer I'm sure but
I'll try wouldn't ask if I didn't think
I'd get a good answer I wouldn't bother
to waste your time or my time I'm
interested that you say you've served
for many years on that Council because
you know so much more about this than I
do but my understanding is that one of
the major problems that has developed is
that um in our wisdom we completely
restructured the department and in
restructuring the department we brought
people together who didn't necessarily
have the same background the same
experience the same understanding how
each of the disperate parts would work
and so that is where I mean I know I I
went and spoke to the commissioner about
the problems she was experiencing trying
to get people to work together and so
I'm interested in
in why that the council that you to
which you refer hadn't undergone any
growing pains well thanks for the
question I I served on it from like
think about 2000 2008 um and I've had
experience with it since then and
getting the uh marker for Hail and Dober
and a couple of other historical markers
we the one for
the the first law enforcement kill on a
duty in the state who was a sheriff in
barington um getting that one put up and
um you know I that was my then
experience with the council about
getting the wording done and the
historical Resources Council which runs
this program to do it and it just it
just seemed um you know functioning as
usual I would not participated in or
part of any of the conversations about
you know concerns about renaming or or
this or that although I will say at the
time um that I was on there there was an
effort we
have I think we pretty much gone now but
back in those in the early 200s it was
noted we had an awful lot of place names
around the state including in Durham you
know and Creek
endpoint um n road down in exitor and
those those were changed um so you know
the process goes on but I I'm just
saying that I think on senat in the
recent yeah the council's still there I
know the counil is but yeah but I the
administrative and management stuff yeah
I understand that but as far as this
goes and I would say this is my point
though is that I I see the logic of
having a legislative touch just how we
issue thank you Mr chairman
um I I heaven forbid 20 years in the
house and I'm finally disagreeing with
my friend from Madbury
um uh well they no longer serve in the
house but I'll tell you later no you
madam
CH oh
[Music]
I'm motion to a jour
oh my God MIAA Mia Mia
Maxima um no no no no there a separation
State you didn't have an Irish
mother there is no separation um let let
me get us back on track by simply saying
I just wonder about us passing any
legislation to have a local community do
something if it could bring up a 91a
issue that's my concern there I like the
idea of having a joint commit of the
legislature looking at this but I don't
necessarily need to be fiscal and um uh
again I think the underlying Bill we all
agree on that's good legislation and I
know we have a lot of memorials here in
conet that have been completely
overlooked and one up at the airport
dedicated to a World War One flyer by
name of Bo Clair CLA is completely
covered with Shrubbery now you can't
even see the marker so I think that's a
wonderful point I did read the NPR
article about uh the um the in with the
story on Oyster River Massacre and how
that's gone all around and who's
involved and what what town was that in
uh that was in the beautiful town of
Durham River in the town of O River my
friend um maybe I'm going mad that's how
mad came up but anyway I do think we
should look at an alternative to have a
disinterested third party look at what a
local community is doing sometimes a
minority in some communities can have a
louder voice than the majority does and
things kind of go along so I do uh
support that idea of a third party thank
you Mr chairman Mr chairman um I had
thought about this we do have the joint
historical
committee um here um Senator Waters is
it myself does
have yeah but at least it would be the
legislature um and we have done the
marker for Lafayette and hanging
portraits in the State House the State
House complex there is some experience
there as opposed to
fiscal just just an idea we have to
amend we'd have to amend the duties of
that yeah we probably would we probably
have he said we'd probably have to amend
the duties of the joint historical
commission I would be very awkward to
add something like this to that
committee because that's it's the state
house yeah it's run it does the State
House they consult with excuse me if I
may Mr they could you know I if I if I
join fiscal and this came in the
department you know the commissioner
came in said here's some here's a
proposal we have and I you know so maybe
Joor some familiar with
the which gives the joint fiscal
committee powers and I don't see how
this would
to would have those Powers would have to
be
amended uh if I may um I think that they
wouldn't because uh anything they do
involves spending a little money and uh
so there's a lot of things that end up
being policy wise that we do we do have
joint fiscal I mean i' we've done a
couple bills this year that have a do a
little pit stop at joint fiscal um and
it's so anyways I I do think it's it's
just a quick question um would fiscal
have the ability for um handling
anything that deals with uh rewriting um
I understand the the money aspect of
fiscal but I can't see them um from a
historical
standpoint handling uh a rewrite or yeah
if I if I may Mr so I I would my sense
would be that the commissioner would
come in say here's what we're going to
do join fiscal would hear about it they
they might say we're not happy with that
language go back and come bring us
something back oh because I I don't want
to sit there and word s no I you imagine
me and English Professor sitting there
and trying to you do you want to scream
for the exits but I I think they would
just say we're not happy with this here
we the first off the
law written is it's marking the location
of public and historic incidents an
incident can't you know we hear about
context no it's not about an incident is
what
happened it's not about the con context
of
it if you go to the uh Arizona under the
uh that's under Pearl Harbor I don't
think there's an area about the context
for the
Japanese it's about here's what
happened and it's when these things that
start
changing or people or we start
uh making adjustments to history based
on people's feelings or Pap or on
context context go to a book and read
about but the mo the
uh the these monuments
are describe the incident that's that
stand
representative yeah sorry about former
represent
yeah being being a chair of house
committee
everybody's Senator Pearl so I'm I'm
listening to the debate and all the
discussion and I certainly appreciate
the representative position that he
brought up and I mean it it is kind of
an arduous task at times to put a bill
all the way through nobody's going to
argue that point perhaps an alternative
would be just to push it have the
executive counsel approve it that way
you're staying within the uh
administrative uh Department as well you
know that's kind of an oversight that
would would stay it isn't us the
legislature but it's giving some
oversight maybe that would be a a better
position it's only let them do the word
SM if they need to they certainly work
with language and finances as
well I don't know any thoughts on that
if I may Mr chairman I I I mean that's
that can be cumbersome too but it is a
lot of things go to the executive
Council that's that's true get it put on
our agenda uh we would lose the
legislative oversight but maybe that's
maybe that's good um but either either
way I I think the basic core principle
that I understood being brought forward
you know for Myers re Hill and with you
Senator has been that um you know we're
elected to uh have a have a look at
things and to set policy and since it
does seem some people have felt that
some decision have gotten into policy
areas then that's an argument for having
it have its
little you know kind of pause uh in the
on the legislative branch rather than
executive I I do think joint FAL work I
think be very efficient and easy to do
and uh we're legislators we know people
en jooin physical we see something come
up on the agenda we have a concern about
we talk to our members on it and um
offer them some insights and that's the
way we do
things continuing continuing to try to
get to yes and do nothing to uh in any
way uh dilute the the value of the
underlying bill um could we why don't we
do what we've done in any number of
situations and actually
create a joint
committee
charged with
reviewing these decisions and it would
have a few members of the house a few
members of the Senate and following
tradition and Rule um the membership
would uh likely roughly reflect the
partisan membership of each of the house
and the Senate I mean you had seven
members on the committee for example um
and that committee uh you don't have to
have a a a bill you don't have to go
through that whole process that
committee could review any um decisions
that have been made either any decisions
that have been made or decisions that
have been um
challenged uh and it would not involve
the entire legislature but it would
involve um it would involve some
legislators and we've done that in I
mean I don't have my blackbook with me
but um you know you could just look at
the blackbook and see how many
committees we've formed to do just that
um and I wonder if that gives us a
chance to have our cake and eat it
too Mr chairman I I think that goes
beyond the what we can do as a committee
of conference because
it either from either body so here here
would be a suggestion i' make I like the
idea how about if we push the effective
date out until
middle of next year July one and you can
put a bill in next fall and we or
someone can whoever's here and have we
can have that discussion and put that
through the legislative process and if
we aren't successful then this will take
effect so if I may u Senator you're the
effective date push it out just for the
second part of the bill correct okay so
we'd have two effective dates in the
bill one and one for only only for this
section yes
yes I I think also the gentleman from
maybe not that I got the right the right
to remain silent I'm going to use the
Fifth Amendment um this was a suggestion
by somebody else but
they thought that possibly The Joint
facilities committee could be the
committee to look at this and just vote
up or down on a
proposal and so I'll off that I think
that's the same if I may Mr it's the
same problem that ID that was identified
with the joint historical you have to
change their I I I think what Senator
Pearl um suggested is workable that we
have an effective date for the first
part push the second part out to give
time for legis the legislation to be
filed that's going to give us a longer
time to look at it and come up with some
sort of a solution so basically we're
dividing the bill yeah you're basically
and just and give time for the
legislative process and hopefully we can
get there yeah so it would be section
three effective date of section
one yeah is 60 days after passage and
then there' be a section
four effective dat of July 1st
2025 that's fine I I just wonder section
two you mean yeah yeah well but do you
have to have a the effective number four
is number four would be the second well
they can't have two effective dates yes
you can have two that's way you
effective date for for part X and then
respect dat for part y but we don't need
a section four we can I where they do it
yes yeah I think before you go too far
down that path um I I am concerned that
what we would be doing would be kicking
the can down the road the bill the bill
everyone knows um has the possib ility
of being derailed anywhere along in this
process and we could go years before we
actually do something um so I I'd like
to suggest um we even we either um jump
into changing this language that we have
the ability to do today by selecting who
would have this oversight with the idea
that future legislation could be um
could be built to build this this
special committee that would do this but
meanwhile we have have something being
worked on that's obviously an issue um
currently um that would be that would be
my hope rather than moving the effective
data on one section or the other um just
simply maybe even choose uh joint fiscal
to look at it now and then the new
legislation could U that is proposed
could change it later on if I may Mr
chairman I I I just think that I I more
talk I think we can work on something
next year right now if we did join fisal
we could be done we'd have a vehicle
that respects the intent of the of the
sponsor of the amendment We'd have the
legisl involved and it be a process that
I think could be effici and uh maybe in
a year from now we've got something else
but for now I think we'd have a
Bill hey and this is not the cannabis
bill okay no I can with that although
there is a there is a museum of cannabis
in Portland r
not that I go into these things but can
I ask you a question of the chair Mr
chairman could I move to divide this
bill because I think we all in agreement
the first part of the bill is good we
think there should be a study of
monuments divide the bill vote on that
and then take up uh uh Senator water's
recommendation for the second part so
that we they could stand
alone it's all or nothing all okay well
so much for that brilliant idea it's
okay one more and I'm out
I I would be fully amenable to changing
it to Joint fiscal I have no issue with
that I think that serves what the point
that we're having some and then we can
have a conversation about a different
Bill another time yeah I just have to
ask how many people sitting in this
table are hoping to be
back you don't have to answer yeah most
of I hope
so okay well I'm not it's all right okay
come back to the
light
she's would everybody ation I can
approach yeah I'm fine either way I I
see the merits of hisor but I'm fine
either way so if I may so we're looking
at language that would begin on line 28
it says resources I'll secure the
approval of the general court through
the joint fiscal committee period 23
yeah yeah I said 23 28 I'm sorry 20 I
don't
have it's in the same I I think um if
you may Mr chair I think that whether we
would say just through the joint fiscal
Committee of the general court I mean I
think that's OS that might tell you how
to do that rather than the general it's
Pro of the general court through the
joint physical committee I don't know
how that should be phrased well I think
that it's the spirit of it yeah so
however all say that should be done my
question is is the do we have to do we
have to change the laws around I don't
Comm I don't think so no that's no no no
they have a lot of flexib have a lot of
I I don't think you do I think they're
okay I serve on joint fiscal as a um as
a alter I I'm pretty sure we could do it
s like other duties so
assigned and and they would have the
approval or disapproval or um do they
then have to get approval from the
general court no
general I we could do that get the bill
passed satisfy the goals of the Senate
satisfi the goals of the House and
Senate which uh is the underlying Bill
and then um we can come in with a bill
right we we we could file a request for
a bill in September um to do to handle
it in a different way but meanwhile I'd
probably even Co with you when you fil
well that would be terrific all I have
to do last have to find out if I'm going
to have a
primary I'll let you know so everybody
be good with that so the official the
official wording is I think we would say
the approval of the joint legislative
fiscal
committee I think that's the the
language and I don't think we need to
reference General Court okay yeah okay I
just looked it up so do does does that
committee take testimony from the public
it oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah
lots of it sometimes right Howard it
does okay basically it would be changing
the changing the amendment to before
amending or permanently removing any
marker is
that the commissioner of the Department
of Natural and cultural resources shall
should shall secure the approval of the
joint fiscal joint legislative fiscal
legislative fiscal
committee period that's it period that's
it period yeah would anybody agree to
adding the word local to public hearings
or do you think that that I think
they're welcomed regardless that's why I
asked the question they would be it's
already in they would be available to
come in and testify before fiscal public
notice public meetings for all joint
physical
okay I think we're all set and I do want
to make sure that in the report that the
chair filed that we emphasized the
absolute uh Universal support of the
basic
bill
um and
against too bad and he writes
the problem
pass the house and our job is support
the house position we are in the house
position that's chair as you read that
was that a motion as you read
out we have to vote
separately are we good says do the
support I'm G ask the
uh committee the the committee of
researcher do you have a do you read
Amendment okay well you're G to
help I will I will I will help you if
you need it okay if you need help I'll
help you draft but but wait a minute the
chair has to agree that the four of us
we only have one vote so it's not as if
we can vote you know three quarters yeah
so that was you agree with this I agree
with it yeah on the on the amendment
I'm changing it to theang the amendment
as I read
sorry
no that's okay as far believing as we
all do in involvement of the public you
can't speak
thanks for
asking but thanks for being here right
this is through
I'll I'll help her with it you going to
help her with it yeah we got get down
the now we have to go
back I'm going
that
e